[Music]
on this Thursday night record heat and a
push to reduce the risk of wildfires
Reviving indigenous methods of managing
forests you will see a big change for
the better and a new warning about the
Summer's Wildfire forecast
the Wagner boss back in Russia sparking
skepticism about his safety
a somber anniversary I have dreams about
what happened Black Meg antique
remembers 10 years after disaster struck
plus mother nature and motherhood does
the summer affect fertility
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us the
last three days were the world's hottest
ever recorded millions of Canadians are
contending with scorching temperatures
with weather warnings now stretching
from coast to coast to coast heat
continues to blanket Southern Ontario
and Quebec and health Canada is adding
new warnings for parts of Atlantic
Canada British Columbia Yukon and the
Northwest Territories special weather
statements for poor air quality are also
in place in several regions while Quebec
is dealing with severe thunderstorm
watches
that prolonged heat has officials urging
people to stay indoors if they can and
doctors are now seeing the impact of
these extreme temperatures Sharia
Israeli has our top story tonight
[Music]
throwing a party gets more complicated
under the scorching Sun we do things
like put out water stations temperatures
are soaring at the height of Festival
season 30 000 people are expected to
pack the opening of ottawa's Annual
Blues Fest and beer won't be the only
thing flowing we up near the front of
the stage we have hoses that we hose
down the audience that's right up front
we have water bottles that get handed
out up there we do everything we can to
help the public stay safe but stay
side even for a few minutes can be
convicted
I could breathe a little bit
a little bit I could breathe enough and
it's hot you get sweaty but I mean you
got to get around somehow and I've got
another 10 minutes to an hour Max and
I'm done for the day the oppressive heat
and unprecedented Wildfire season are
creating a dangerous combination Vin
Ottawa we have not seen this degree of
air pollution respirologists are dealing
with a surge in patients this summer
we're seeing more people calling who are
sick in the last two or three weeks and
are needing treatment for their
underlying lung disease which has gotten
worse
Ottawa is urging people to stay inside
and stay hydrated to avoid straining
hospitals over the last few weeks in
particular we have seen emergency
departments
significantly impacted the Canadian
climate Institute studies the health
effects of a warming Planet a recent
report estimates by the middle of the
century the sweltering heat will cause
an additional 400 deaths a year in
Canada and cost the Health Care System
an extra four billion dollars annually
the evidence is clear that this is a
real threat for Canada it could affect
the country somewhere anytime any summer
relief is on the way with the extreme
heat expected to taper off but higher
than normal temperatures are in the
forecast all summer meaning more risk
for the vulnerable and more pressure on
the Health Care System Jeff Taria Israel
Ottawa thanks to Ria
and that heat is fueling a wildfire
season unlike anything Canada has seen
before today government officials and
experts offered their Wildfire forecast
for the coming months and warned the
worst is far from over
drought conditions when coupled with
above normal temperatures across most of
the country means that the risk of fire
activity is going to remain very high
throughout the majority of the summer in
July most of Canada from British
Columbia and the North through to the
Prairies and across the country to
Western Labrador will be at high risk
here are the latest numbers more than
640 fires are burning right now across
the country of those more than half are
out of control but it's the total from
the past couple of months that's most
staggering so far this year Canada has
seen more than 3 400 wildfires and some
88 thousand square kilometers have
burned that's more than 10 times the
average from the past decade as a result
000 Canadians have been forced from
their homes the most in nearly half a
century
Canada has called for backup with more
than 3 200 firefighting Personnel
arriving from around the world but more
assistance is needed and there are calls
for the government to remove obstacles
so indigenous communities can help
Heather urich's West reports
when a wildfire burned out of control in
late May more than 800 people of Fort
chippewan North of Fort McMurray were
forced from their homes I did get
emotional you know
thinking God please make sure your
community's safe with no summer Road
access the community had to be evacuated
by air over three anxious days even
though indigenous people only make up
five percent of the Canadian population
they make up 42 percent of wildfire
evacuees so it's a really
disproportionate impact on those
communities with that impact only
expected to intensify Wildfire
researcher Amy Cardinal Christensen
believes it's time traditional
indigenous ways of managing Canada's
forests are restored but when you're
actually living on that land you can
really see like okay Now's the Time To
Burn what they did with fire was
basically to bring things closer to them
so they would produce like a mosaic on
the landscape so for example they would
burn near their settlement so that you
know grass would come up earlier so that
then they could have deer and moose that
would come to the area to eat British
Columbia was the first Province to
Outlaw cultural burning in 1874. the
rest of Canada followed in the early
1900s but on her own private property
Cardinal Christensen has brought the
practice back maintaining this fire
break on her land near Rocky Mountain
House because if we weren't doing this
this would just grow over and we'd
pretty much have a continuous Forest
here
done at the end of winter or in the very
late fall and accompanied with a
ceremony Cardinal Christensen says the
burning promotes a healthy Forest while
reducing the risk of wildfires growing
out of control it's a practice
indigenous leaders say many communities
are longing to do if we were to have
more access
in the ceremonies
you will see a big change for the better
I can't walk around
like I used to when I was a kid because
the force is too dense Parks Canada has
started to work with indigenous Partners
to bring cultural Burns and other
traditional practices back but in order
to make a difference swing around in
here Cardinal Christensen says they will
have to occur regularly on a scale that
allows large areas of forests and the
communities within them to benefit
Heather urich's West Global News near
Rocky Mountain House Alberta
with many relying on air conditioning
this week Montreal is reporting a
widespread power outage tonight
affecting nearly two hundred thousand
customers a little later in the newscast
we'll take a closer look at how
Canadians without AC are struggling to
stay cool
well as we first reported yesterday
Ottawa has struck a deal with stalantis
and LG Energy Solutions to resume
construction of their electric vehicle
battery plant in Windsor Ontario and
we're now learning how much the federal
and provincial governments are willing
to pay to keep the wheels in motion the
two companies are set to receive up to
15 billion dollars in performance
incentives Mackenzie gray looks at
whether that money is well spent
it's one of the largest corporate
subsidies in Canadian history European
car maker stalantis getting a 15 billion
dollar deal from the federal and Ontario
governments our government was
absolutely determined that Canada get
its fair share of those green jobs the
agreement sees construction of an
electric vehicle battery plant resuming
in Windsor after the car maker and their
South Korean partner LG energy walked
away from the plant in May
stalantis which owns Brands such as
Dodge Jeep and Fiat wanted Canada to
cough up more cash saying the original
deal of a billion dollars from the feds
in Province wasn't enough to keep up
with massive new American subsidies in
Joe Biden's inflation reduction act if
they were a thousand yards over the
Border they'd be collecting billions of
dollars in tax breaks and so this is uh
an historic response those billions will
create an estimated 2500 new jobs that
works out to 6 million per employee but
the union representing those workers
says it's about the sector overall this
is also secures thousands and thousands
of jobs that we already have in Windsor
and Brampton Ontario's one-third share
is based on tax credits which will more
than cover the 5 billion dollar cost to
build the plant it will also dwarf money
spent another major liberal promises
five years of dental care said at 13
billion dollars yesterday's increase to
the GST tax credit a mere 2.5 billion
and if both governments wanted to stay
in the car game they could have 22
percent of stalantis for the same amount
of money well I'm not sure that
stalantis would describe it as blackmail
but I think a lot of people would might
in more casual conversation provide
similar verbiage both governments signed
a similar deal previously giving 13
billion in subsidies to Volkswagen to
build a similar electric battery plant
in St Thomas Ontario and more companies
are looking for comparable deals we
can't do everyone
we could probably do another two or
three and if those deals do materialize
The Innovation Minister says Canada is
willing to give similar subsidies to
attract more business
Jeff Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mack
the Wagner mercenary leader who led a
brief Mutiny against the Kremlin is
reportedly back on Russian soil if true
it marks an unexpected twist and a power
struggle that's threatened President
Putin's Authority
today in a show of force Russia launched
a missile attack on an apartment
building in the western city of leviv
far from the front lines and home to
thousands displaced by the war five
people were killed and as Redmond
Shannon reports the mayor is calling it
the largest attack on civilian
infrastructure in leviv since the start
of the invasion
pain and grief in a Ukrainian city that
has mostly escaped the worst of this war
the Russians say they only hit military
objects says this woman people were
asleep here how could they do this leviv
is just 90 minutes from the border with
NATO member Poland
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
promised revenge against Russia as he
visited another NATO country Bulgaria
ratcheting up pressure for NATO
membership after the war
on the other side of the conflict
Vladimir Putin's biggest Ally boasted
about his newly acquired Russian nuclear
bombs Bella Russia's Alexander
lukashenka also threw a new verbal
grenade into the pragossian Mutiny Saga
he said the Wagner mercenary boss is no
longer in Belarus but Saint Petersburg
Russia insisting Putin won't kill him
[Applause]
less than two weeks ago lukashenka
claimed to have brokered a deal with
Putin and pragosian to end the
short-lived Rebellion at that time he
claimed to have welcomed the notorious
mercenary boss to Belarus a deal which
supposedly gave progossians safety let's
be honest Alexander lukashenko is a man
very comfortable with lying to the world
on Russian State TV this week footage of
an apparent raid on pragossians Saint
Petersburg Mansion included a photo of a
cabinet of wigs two Western media
reports sabrigation went back to get
some of these weapons despite Russian
media claims criminal investigations
against him remain open give any
pragosian is a survivor and I don't
think he would be making this decision
if he thought that he couldn't survive
it and let's be honest he has
significant resources at his disposal
the fate of those resources Productions
Army of mercenaries may be up for grabs
too lukashenka cryptically said moving
troops to Belarus still depends on the
decisions of the Kremlin and Wagner
group Redmond Shannon Global News London
the U.S has released video of what it
says are Russian fighter jets flying
dangerously close to American drones in
Syria
the footage shows the Jets setting off
parachute flares near the drones
appearing to block their view the U.S
says the drones were monitoring targets
of the so-called Islamic State and were
not armed the Americans called Russia's
Behavior Reckless representing a new
level of unsafe action Russia has been a
strong supporter of the Syrian regime in
its long bloody Civil War
fatal fire
coming up firefighters are killed after
a cargo ship erupts in flames
[Music]
in New Jersey two firefighters have been
killed battling flames on board an
Italian cargo ship carrying more than
one thousand vehicles and containers
that fire erupted at around 9 30
Wednesday night while the ship was
docked at the Port of Newark one of the
busiest on the U.S east Coast an
investigation into the fire is now
underway
across Canada many people are upgrading
to an air conditioning unit as these
hotter days become the norm but that's
not an option for everyone and gaviola
explains why renters are among the most
vulnerable in this extreme weather
it's unbearable Rob castle and other
renters in his building say they haven't
had AC during this heat wave they've
been told the landlord is working on it
I have a one week old son so he's not
coping with this weather very well and
our heat is just
brutal situations like this are the
reason the city of Hamilton is next year
set to become the first place in Canada
requiring landlords to provide air
conditioning on the hottest days the
bylaw sets a maximum heat standard for
indoor spaces 26 degrees Celsius renters
do not have the ability to affect
the structure of the homes that they
live in to the same degree that
homeowners or condo owners do some are
more vulnerable to the Mercury climbing
those most at risk of heat related
deaths and illness are seniors people
with disabilities low-income households
and racialized and tenant communities
exposure to excessive heat is dangerous
when your cognitive function starts to
be affected that's when you know in
addition to the high temperature that
it's in medical emergency and you should
head to the hospital call 9-1-1 right
away climate experts say this trend is
poised to get much worse especially in
cities with lots of people roads and
congestion the urban heat island effects
is basically the phenomenon that means
that cities are hotter than the
surrounding rural areas raising the risk
for tenants in densely populated parts
of the country it not only can surfaces
be times to 15 degrees hotter in cities
they can they actually retain the heat a
warning call to protect the most
vulnerable as heat waves become more
frequent and more intense and gaviola
Global News Toronto
Family Planning still ahead a new study
suggests the summer can impact in vitro
fertilization
[Music]
welcome back prospective parents who are
going through the in vitro fertilization
process may have a new way to increase
their odds of success a study out of
Australia suggests the time of year when
eggs are retrieved could influence the
outcome Catherine Ward explains
cries and little hands
Small Wonders that can make an IVF
Journey well worth struggle and loss as
Vanessa Robinson knows all too well
having James and seeing him and holding
him
it's really Indescribable it's the
greatest reward possible at the end of a
of a difficult Journey for some people
becoming a parent takes time lots of
memories these days are transferred or
placed back in the womb having been
frozen for months and sometimes years
new data out of Australia indicates that
for frozen embryo transfers the season
in which eggs are retrieved is one
factor that influences the outcome we
found that if the egg had been collected
um in summer as opposed to in Autumn
which is where we saw the lowest live
birth rates the odds of having a live
birth in reoccurrence though were 30
higher regardless of when the embryo
actually went back while doctors haven't
been able to fully explain the link
researchers believe melatonin could be
part of the equation but Canadian
fertility specialist Dr Evan Turk says
there are other factors to consider is
it the sunshine that's doing it is it
other behavioral factors such as diet
Lifestyle the air quality we know that
changes from season to season and then
there's the other half of the
reproductive equation the sperm there's
not really a lot of sperm information so
could these same seasonal effects that
may be impacting the eggs also be
affecting the male Factor side where
applicable but even as researchers learn
more they say Family Planning should
continue on a track that's right for the
parents regardless of the Season
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
up next 10 years since one of Canada's
deadliest rail disasters lack megantic
marks a painful anniversary
[Music]
ten years on from one of Canada's worst
ever rail disasters residents in the
tightly knit community of Lac megantic
Quebec say they will never forget today
the town of around 6 000 gathered for a
commemorative Mass honoring the 47 lives
lost when a runaway train carrying crude
oil derailed in the middle of town
for those who live in lakmagantic life
has never been the same and as Dan
Spector explains today was about
reflection and also making sure a
similar tragedy never happens again
[Music]
the bells at the Saint Agnes Church told
47 times one for each of those who died
on that horror-filled night a decade
after the disaster that marked this
small town forever emotions are still
raw
Yolanda lost her 19 year old grandson
that night she was among the hundreds
attending a commemorative mass that the
church just steps from where a runaway
train hauling millions of tons of crude
oil derailed and exploded on July 6 2013
leaving much of the downtown area
completely devastated The Inferno
engulfed her grandson's apartment
it's not normal for a grandmother to
live through the death of a grandchild
she says every night sometime I have
dreams about like Megan sick and what
happened Danilo Zone was the fire chief
back then he says he's doing better now
but dark memories still haunt him like
when a little girl asked if he'd seen
her parents but he knew they were gone I
said no I didn't you see them I wish I
could sit them people from surrounding
towns and Beyond gathered in
lachmegantic to Mark the Grim
anniversary
hundreds attended the commemorative Mass
including the Prime Minister and members
of his cabinet Justin Trudeau took the
opportunity to underline how work should
finally start this fall to move the
tracks out of the now rebuilt downtown
it's been a longer process than anyone
would have liked years of negotiations
have resulted in expropriations Yolanda
Belanger is opposed to the current plan
the trains would go right through her
land
it's harmful she says pointing to the
environmental destruction that will
result others just want to see the
tracks leave town
because a tragedy may happen anytime
while not everyone agrees on the future
of the tracks many found value in
Remembering together
[Music]
inspector Global News Quebec
and that is global national for this
Thursday night I'm Jeff Semple and our
thoughts tonight are with the people of
Lac megantic remembering the 47 lives
lost from that rail disaster 10 years
ago thanks for watching have a good
night
thank you
foreign
[Music]